[音楽]
始めるん
はじめのハロウィン嫌いなのかいあ
フッカー昔ハロウィンの日に東京に行って人が多すぎて全く動けなくなってそこに帰れ
なくてすげー嫌な思いをしたんだ
そうなんだねー
[音楽]
ずつは恥じる社長です
お任せしましたはじめしゃちょー秋の質問コーナー
あーうしゃいみなさんこんにちは第18会始めの質問コナへようこそ
お菓子まで2ヶ月弾み社長ですそれではさっそく本米どうぞ
もう18回目なんだね今回もずう5万件以上のコメント頂けました本当にいつも
ありがとうございます今回特徴的だったのはまあ ct とちょっと意味不明の
コメントは以上に高却下です
なかなかもそれ米たが多かったんですけども今回もそんなんから選んレイヤーで
選び抜いたコメントに応えていこうと思いますでは行こう
boa 1おいさ
頬張りこれからも動画頑張って裁縫針じゃねえパティがとアスパラですこれからも
頑張ればスパないカスじゃねえはアウディなど最後の食べ物に例える方めちゃくちゃ
おい寄与するんですけど青イソメをいそうねそうねじゃあね多い人参元気感じじゃねえ
は元気だよエコ付でがんばれーオフ電車姉マ
アニーが遠いエビジャンえびてんじゃねーば期待をしないがこれからも頑張る
よありがとう多い中にも長いもじゃねぇ長芋さんに失礼です
長芋に謝れ
俺が悪いみたいになってるを1んぺらー頑張れよ沈殿したねーはすごいコメントから
もう多い牛丼がバレエをゲージとんじゃねぇはもうでいるかどうかもわからん
保育次も二木もじゃねぇまぁ少し落ち着け落ち着きます追い始め
神殿死なねばバカやる新ランクが10袋ねキャビアフォアグラトリュフ
図書ん水本でるんレッスン巨木やピョン感度ゾーンに嫌われたかもしれない
源さん line をブロックされましたこれって嫌われたんです完全に嫌われてます
よ
コナン君肇社長のこと大好きですまず目を応援してまーかーではございますすみません
間違いましたら違いで外れ社長さんや自分はするのがとても怖いで性別として生まれた
からには4
というものは避けられないものですがどうポジティブに考えても怖いですどうすれば
怖くなくなりますか後肇社長でも知れば怖いですか生き物というものは生きた瞬間いつ
か死ぬので死ぬのは僕は仕方ないと思っています僕もするのは怖いですけどいつ死んで
もいいようにはいつもしたいことをして暴れてます皆さんもぜひ
後悔のないように後悔のない毎日を
過ごしてください
ぴんぐさん l でデレデレねー
ええええっ特になぜ
へんっはぁっいやー県パイナップアップ始めした張棟圭もうおーっ
あの世へ go バナーのカードですってあっていこう
[音楽]
なんか君たちすごいコンビネーションの良いでおっぱいは好きですか
そりゃもちろんダイス大好きです右辺兵なんですか
なんでもないです私もおっぱい好きでだへ twitter に会いたいなぁとかあぁ
好きだなーとか意味深なツイートして皆が反応が見てなるほどこれは面白いなぁ
一回やってみましょうかなぜでをロボやっちゃ
四つ目てみますえっ
ああいうやつべちょっと触れちゃったんでもう判断があって鯉あ世界一
ウバまでバイバイすぎ反応してくれる人となんかもなんか
a みたいな感じなのがたくさん降った
こういう感じにされちゃうんですよね
鳥の頭に頭を突っ込んでくださいん
みかん星人になってて言ったじゃんしろよ
月潭あなた子ですか
嫌いな雄2羽のなお良さげんで嫌いというかちょっと気に食わねぇ涙ネットはいますよ
割と
そんなにないなぁなんか本当にゴジラ好きでやってるのかなみたいなツラば好きじゃ
ないですよね肇社長は真面目な質問です人生の中で一番大変だったことつらかったこと
を嫌がったことは何ですか
嬉しかったことと見せかけて死にそうになったことは不評だなぁ
水陰性で一番繋がる一番大変だったこと
もやし鍋に湯田れそうになった時つなかったことうーん足並みに入れる
れたこと嫌だったことんもやし鍋にされて僕だけ食べ残されたこと全部言うじゃねえ
ちゃんやー
全長してその間にファンへのひと言あんまりいつも言えないが言うけどさ
いつも応援してくれる人本当にいっぱいライター
始め別に何度か乳首にしてそこでファン感謝バイしませんか
始めなら人数集まらず実現可能だと思います正直ねディズニー勝ちきればアリス米機会
があったらやろうと思うんでみんなでディズニー生かし切ろうぜ
騎兵かー
割とそのアイコン好きだよバイトリーダーなんですけど後半への起こり方が分かりませ
ん起こりの見本を見せてください
僕もコンビニでバイトリーダーみたいなことやってたんですけどやっぱしっかりない
せいで怖くていらっしゃいませ
いらっしゃいませいましたいらっしゃいませんです
スバル0 j をさんは者
ソースよ叫びながら外を走ってみたくないですかさあ今すぐ外へ
セクショ
セクション畜生っくしょー月ちゃ
俺は俺は何で武力なんだあああ
いいともやってやる無力なラザク者のどこでやってやれるか見せてやるよ
俺はねがー俺はこの世代よ
この無力の作者がどこまでも弱いしてかにゃ無限の可能性であふれた世界に変えてある
[音楽]
なんで言わせたいければ何で
もありません
おいこれは採用旋回ビットンカラー用喧嘩するしかないじゃん割とガチで好きな女性の
タイプ
何だろうなあやっぱりしっかりした女性はキュンときますならしっかりした人に神創
くんみたいな感じでこう
構えられたでしたらもう
キュッときますね何言ってんだ俺始めそうの尊敬している人はないですから友達た
有名人など誰でもいいで一番憧れている人は実は物販賛成です
あの人の名前が思い出せんぞスチールがこれは終わりの始めたことや
忘れたくなかった人をズレちゃダメな人
聲の形ああ
こういう容姿なのは玉ねぎ食べてください
あ
意外とう受験の時の息出来はどうしたらいいですか
息抜きする時間すらもったいなくてずっと勉強してたんですけど勉強中に強いと目で靴
をずっと食べてましたねほんとはないものをくるとね心が幸せになるんだよああ
あずったい採用されタービンっ
殺すぞおい d
腕とずれすみませんいけないそんな暴言を言うのは良くないです
自分が言われたら嫌な気持ちになりますよね彼がとても面白いしユーチューバーの中で
も一番好きです
僕はそんなカレーをこれからも応援してますそういうことでこれからも頑張って
ください
百均さんそっち千房動機を教えてもらえますか
にベチャってぬビジョンで蔵書んん
ウェゾン部署 bandel 味噌軍 pro 石井一主義
親世帯増第二弾 os os も安い
ヨコモ s も se は安い
どっちいい
嘘だよありがとね彼女はいる先輩に告白したら別に俺は迷惑じゃないって言われたんだ
けど
縁はだか怪しすぎる彼女がいるのに迷惑じゃない
怪しい匂いがすぐ今すぐにでもヘビ型テストのファンに価値ねー
生徒今こそ勉強にパフねなぜなら続けるのさっ丁目
教唆と弱者はキャー
キャップペリーズ冊ため別宅なぁ
とりあえずねーよ早速展開早俺
アイオークやなにおけるんだぞとネロやっぱ
ab 3秒で納豆を食べてください
[音楽]
22ですか僕は大好きです22委員に身にしそれなそれ
w ああああ
続けてバーンされピットああ
ああああああ
feel bar
goo
ノートルドラやめてあげようや片面が可哀想だろう
のようにぶわぁ
[音楽]
me
ああ
本日パンッ待って待って待ってほんとちゃんたらまだいるだろうに対するので
っていう意味が再コメントありがとうございました
質問コーナー愛子はえっもう痛いのやめようね
いやーホント皆さんええっ立っ
春だ車ああ痛い痛い
ばいばい